when apartheid ended almost 30 years ago
millions of south africans like dorian
and gamer hope for a future of equality
opportunity and prosperity for her her
children
and her grandchildren it hasn't turned
out like that
things are worsened since
since this democracy
but there's no democracy here
there's no democracy at all doreen's
story is one of frustration
and wasted potential a story familiar to
millions across this country
i was interested in going maybe
universities away but i couldn't afford
it
because it's too much
i couldn't afford it but i was so
interested in
being something having some profession
but i can't dorian's daughter
says she's not got the right connections
to get a job
a 70 through would say we're not working
because those who are in higher
positions they only look after their
friends or their family
so it's not going to be easy for our
kids to get jobs because we don't know
people in high places
the world bank says that south africa is
now the most unequal
society in the world the top 10
of earners take home 65
of the income and white people are still
more likely to find work
and better paid work than their black
counterparts
the widespread rioting and looting that
swept through parts of south africa last
week
was sparked by the jailing of former
president jacob zuma
but it was chronic poverty and
unemployment that spurred on
the violence the poorest have been the
main victims
more people are now jobless after the
destruction of shops
warehouses and factories totally totally
surprised it's taking us back
unaware not prepared at all and we felt
there's a need because
obviously there's no jobs people are
hungry
no money to buy food they got money they
can't get food
doreen would at least like her
grandchildren to have a fair
chance the future i wish for them
is to get the best education they can
get
but i don't see that happens in this
world we are living in now they're
growing up in a country where half the
population lives below the poverty line
now president cyril ramaphosa says that
rioting and looting was deliberately
orchestrated to cause maximum damage to
infrastructure
and supply chains the police say they
have about
12 suspected instigators that they want
to speak to
four of them have been arrested so far
and could well
appear in court on monday
that's bernard smith talking to us from
durban bernard thank you